the great masters of marine as if
calling themselves such could make them
so thousands of years ago during the
height of the ghiscari empire marine was
second only to old keys in wealth and
glory a paradise by the sea if one
didn't mind the constant clinking of
chains and cracking whips slaves booked
marine and on their backs the city
rested like a litter then came the
Dragons of Valyria the masters of old
geese were not bow so they burned the
Valerians tore down their walls burned
their pyramids to ash and sewed they're
filled with salt and skulls an old slave
woman once told me that the Valyrians
intended to break the chains of the
cascara slaves absorbing them into the
Valyrian freehold where every man held a
vote but the great masters of murine
received their new overlords in the
great temple plying them with gold wine
and all the wealth that slavery had
brought them and the Valerians instead
took up the whip themselves I do not
believe it as their empire expanded the
Valerians needed more and more bodies to
feed their minds and colonies when no
wage could ever tempt a free man the
great masters merely accommodated their
new customers staying rich as the
ghiscari empire crumbled after the doom
fell on Valyria the great masters
worried for their fortunes by this time
the Valerians were their greatest
providers and purchases of slaves then
the Dothraki horselord swept out of the
plains of Essos and proved to be as fond
of slaving as the Dragonlords before
them the great masters grew richer still
for the first time in its history the
great masters alone ruled marine and
chaos ruled the rest of the world the
fighting pits swallowed men who in
previous centuries would have filled the
ranks of the Valyrian armies without
these soldiers to maintain order the
wealthy had to buy their own which the
good masters of a stupor were more than
willing to sell if the buyers nerves
still needed calming the wise masters of
yunkai could sell him
further release the great masters the
good masters the wise masters yet none
was so great good or wise that they
recognized our queen for what she was
her ancestors had destroyed them then
become them perhaps they assumed she
would bend as easily but our queen does
not bend she breaks
you